SKKKKKKKKKRA HAHOO
Let's begin!
YOU LAUGH YOU LOSE
Skrattar du, förlorar du!
Season 1, episode 1!
Pilot!
Prequel, Beta verSioN, vErsiOn aLPha, 1.1,  lets frickin' DO THIS
LESt JUST JUMP INTO It
DAMMNN
So the rules are simple, you laugh you lose.
Smash like right now to accept this challenge.
And smash like-
*to beat T-Series*
If you are watching this video right now.
Let's *frikin* do dis
I am excited!
Whaddya got?
"MAA!" [Mom]
"PUT THE DOGS AWAY THERE'S SOMETHING IN THE BACKYARD!"
"MA! PUT THE *expletive* DOGS AWAY"
What is it, a raccoon?
"THERE'S SOMETHING IN THE BACKYARD!"
A homeless person?
"AH!"
What is that- Oh, it's a cat.
"AHHH!"
Oh my god!
"WHAT THE F- HE'S BACK!"
"OHHH!"
Eugh!
"MAAA!!!"
EUGH!
"CALL THE *expletive* COPS!"
"THE CAT IS BACK! EEHH!"
"Call the cops"... *chuckles*
*realizes*
Stupid ugly cat!
Is that real, is that- like makeup?
It's wearing makeup?
Wilfred... Wilfred Warrior.
Oh my god...
Oh... Oh my god.
*Questioning life.*
Wilfred.
*chuckles while talking* Wilfred!
Come on, it doesn't count if it's Wilfred.
I didn't know it was Wilfred.
Health back, please!
Namaste!
That's freakin'- OMG!
"First you get your human, then you wrap up your human... *bed croaks*
"Okay, say 1-2-3 go!" *says*
"And this is how to package her!" *CRASH*
*laughs*
How to kill your sister, everyone!
Let's frickin' do this! *claps*
"1-2-3 go!"
"And this is how to package her!"
*CRASH*
Okay, looks like I'm still in the game, boys!
Oh god.
*yeet*
*laughs*
That is not funny!
PETA, please unsubscribe right now, I don't need your judgment here.
That was funny.
"My dude just yote a gator."
Ya ever yeet a gator? *giggles*
Ya ever- *stumbles* (yoted a gator before?)
Hey look it's my channel! *smile*
"Yeah.. I'm just gonna say..."
"Hey man, I really appreciate your content."
"You've gotten me through some tough times."
"And I respect the f-"
*laughs*
Pewds (ingame): "Oh no!"
I didn't know if this would be funny just for me.
or if it was funny for other people because-
I- I always really appreciate it when fans are- y'know express their gratitude or whatever.
But I never know how to respond,
idk, like- thank you?
It's all I can really say, but...
"Hey man, I really appreciate your content."
"You've gotten me through some tough times."
Look at the guy! Look at the guy.
Ahh, you can't ask for better comedic timing than that.
Alright, I don't think i'm doing very well by the way, what's my health?
les check it out
Looks like I'm still winning.
SMASH like if you're also
a person
Jimmy: Just a little sodium chloride.
Waiter: ...Actually dude it's salt!
Jimmy: *interrupts* That's what I said!
Waiter: No dude, you said sodium chloride,
That's the same as salt,
but you could have just said salt instead.
Everyone in this town knows you're a boy genius dude.
You don't need to say overly large words,
to sound more intelligent.
The fact of the matter is, that nobody cares how smart you are.
If anything, if calling simplistic objects by their scientific names,
ironically makes you seem less intelligent, and more pompous.
I know you're smart enough to be better than this. *cut*
By the way,
I think I can pull off a Jimmy Neutron haircut.
ehehe
Ya gotta do tha- ya gotta do the swirl.
OH YEAHH! :D
OH YEAHH!
"At what age did my lead up- lead ups- when did my Tourettes start?"
"it started when i touched a d***."
It started when i was-... *everyone in the lobby laughs*
I think- I think Dave told me about her,
cause she... She had a tic of (bitch lasagna).
I don't know if it's her, but I- lemme chec
"Are you planning on playing any other games on this channel?"
"I do play other games sometimes,
I'm currently working on a- with a potato PC."
"So..."
"It's given me up on me a few times when I've tried to play other games."
"But I do play The Forest, I play Bioshock."
"I play with my d*** on a tuesday,
*expletive* you and Jesus- *expletive* you-"
"Bitch lasagna- bitch."
"Lasagna."
"*tic* bitch lasagna."
Oh no...
What have I done!
I think she mentioned that she's okay with people laughing about it.
That's why- okay.
Beyond Two Souls, but 500% facial animations.
Great.
"Dr. Matthews is going to have to care for you from now on."
"He's really nice."
Oh god!
"He wants to meet you."
"Come on hurry up."
"I'll be right here sweetheart."
Oh is this facial animations, okay that's great...
"Hello Jodie, come in."
Oh! Oh no.
Dafoe please no.
"My name is Nathan... Nathan Dawkins."
"I found it would be a good idea for us
to have a little chat to get to know each other a little bit."
Oh god, please no please!
"That is... if it's okay with you of course."
What is happening, how do you make these (videos)?
"You like it?"
I wonder if they did a Beyond Two-
"You can have it if you want."
OH MY GOD STOP.
Oh, they have they have! OK, Let's check it out.
"I found you, by the side of the road."
"In the middle of nowhere."
"Was there an accident?"
"Did someone try to hurt you?"
omg... *giggles*
Oh! Oh no not the dogs!
DPO23, please...
Please make one...
What is it called, Detroit- Detroit Become Human.
That would be so good...
Oh, I would love that.
"Bruh Sound Effect #2"
"No what are you doing, what are you doing! NO! What are you doing, what are you doi- NOOO!!"
*intense reactions*
Is that a thing? Honestly, I'd kinda want to hear it.
What is "bruh sound effect- three" sound like?
*undertale*
uh, of course.
Of course, how could I have been
so
stewpid!!!!
Obviously.
"Officers in Lancaster, Pennsylvania
we're asking people to be on the lookout for
a man who robbed the store."
"And I think, yeah."
"I think we do- we do have this description-"
"Can we take that? Let's take this description."
*stunned*
What is he an elf?
"OK..."
"This is the guy that had uh- they wanted people in Pennsylvania to be out on the lookout for."
"He's got uh..."
"Well, he's got a nose some hair that goes like that."
He's got a nose, and some hair!
"It was uh- he's wearing a hat! At the time in this particular... Particular crime."
*dying* IS THIS REAL? PLEASE BE REAL!
"He's got a kind of a... chin that comes down to a... almost to a point."
"Standing on 5'4 inches tall! There it is. A good look for yourself."
"Now we are hearing the police actally caught this guy!"
OH THEY CAUGHT HIM!
"So. Here's a picture of the real guy, next to the
*bursts out laughing* ...sketch. After his arrest."
"It's uncanny!"
Ahhh, that can not be real! I hope it is though.
God damn it.
Ah geez! Ah, geez! Looks like I'm real low.
Ah, guys! It looks like I'm gonna have to tap out.
sowree
We'll sple-explain the rest of the clips without me.
Ah that would make it easier.
All genders, all punchers, all people...
"Were are gamers?"
Oh my god, thank you.
Finally a man that sees beyond, the wall.
Where are gamers!?
(Someone caption this please? Thanks.)
It makes me so sick that gamers keep having to... face this, sort of...
Discrimination.
What the hell is your problem duckling!
I'll have you killed!
I'll have your whole family killed. This is not a threat, it's facts.
*crab rave*
What the frick!
Oh ye! (unintelligible)
Subscribe to pewdiepie, alright, you're fine. You're back in the game Dolan.
Fine.
"Waluigi number one! *crowd cheering*
"WAHH!!"
"AWW NO!"
"Waluigi no win this time."
That was great *claps*.
"WAHHH!!"
Thank you for watching another episode of-
SKRATTAR DU, FÖRLORAR DU MANNEN.
An *epic* episode I will say, that was pretty epic.
Yeah. yeah, let's go with that.
I'll see you guys tomorrow on the next episode of...
;]
What I will upload tomorrow.
I'll see you guys tomorrow!
BAI!